PAIGE BAILEY: Thanks to
an incredible and diverse
community, TensorFlow
has grown to become
one of the most loved
and widely adopted
machine learning
platforms in the world.
This community
includes researchers
who use TensorFlow to do
things like forecast earthquake
aftershocks and
detect breast cancer,
developers who are using it
to identify disease plants
into perfect yoga
poses, companies
who are using TensorFlow
to improve their customer
experience, and of
course, all of you.
We're so excited to have you
as part of our community.
TensorFlow recently
celebrated its third birthday,
with a look back at the features
added through the years.
We're excited about another
major milestone, TensorFlow
2.0.
TensorFlow 2.0 will
focus on simplicity
and ease of use, featuring
updates like easy model
building with Keras and
Eager execution, robust model
deployment, and production
on any platform,
powerful experimentation
for research,
and simplifying the
API by cleaning up
deprecated endpoints and
reducing duplication.
We're very excited about
TensorFlow 2.0 and the changes
to come.
TensorFlow has grown
from a software library
for deep learning to
an entire ecosystem
for all kinds of
machine learning
from complex neural networks
to traditional methods
to AI on mobile and
embedded devices.
TensorFlow 2.0 will be
simple and easy to use
for all users of any experience
level on all platforms.
So why wait?
Try out the nightly
build of TF 2.0 today.
We're excited to
see what you create.